every kopec counts as russians begin to
feel the effect of sanctions on their
economy
one dollar bought 75 rubles before the
war now it buys a hundred that means
higher prices for imported goods such as
the fruit and veg in this market
sweets used to cost 70 rubles now they
cost 100 and chicken also we don't leave
a luxury life but the prices went up
notably
the price of sugar went up significantly
more than 10 rubles
i ran out of salt and sugar and i
couldn't find them now today they
appeared
my pension would be enough it is not so
little but i spend almost half of it on
medicines so very little remains
everything is more expensive sorry fish
used to be 120 rubles now it's 480. last
time we bought buckwheat almost 200 very
expensive it's hard for us we want to
eat
russian president vladimir putin has
acknowledged that sanctions mean the
economy will need what he calls deep
structural changes they won't be easy he
said before the war in ukraine inflation
here was already over nine percent the
highest it's been in seven years that
could now double and interest rates are
at twenty percent all of this putting a
real squeeze on russian incomes
[Music]
at the russian association of patriotic
entrepreneurs some believe there are
opportunities to be had as western firms
pull out though first there are
practical challenges to work around
the whole supply chain has been damaged
many producers are not sending raw
materials or finished products to russia
even if they are containers aren't
leaving because of concerns about
sanctions so a big question for
processing industries is what is the
logistic chain the ruble dollar exchange
rate is also a big stress
many russians credit their president
with stabilizing the economy after the
collapse of the soviet union
it grew every year vladimir putin was in
office until the global financial crisis
a group of international banks now
expects economic output to fall by up to
a third this year
bernard smith al jazeera moscow